all right okay
thank you good morning everybody welcome
to our plans committee the 9th of june
um welcome to those who may be watching
on youtube on
youtube
and welcome to everybody in the at the
meeting
i'll start by asking the committee and
officers to introduce themselves i'll
start with myself i'm councillor chris
leather
uh and i represent new orleans
council pete watson i represent broadly
council roosevelt and i represent two
rivers and three walls
good morning my name
grady is i represent
east
hello richard weissman i represent the
chevrolet pantry award
good morning i'm richard and i represent
part of the war
good morning my name is dan goff and i
represent biddeford north
and then
our office is starting on my website
good morning i'm helen smith i'm
planning manager
good morning i'm stacey i'm head of
league one governments
good morning christian eagley
team leader
tom brownstone democratic services
manager
democratic services
good morning
to protection
lovely thank you
we're not expecting the fire drill this
right
i think one on the agenda's apologies
for absence but
no apology you've got full house
item two on the agenda are the minutes
of the meeting
held on the 12th of mary pages 5 to
eighteen in your agenda yeah
on page eight
uh the second table then
i voted against default
but it was seven four and two against
right
with that one
type
alteration i'll move from the chair
those minutes
council watson seconded
could you take the vote on that please
samuel thank you chair
councillor mountain
four
brown
council christie
[Music]
thank you
i can see on the agenda declarations of
interest
members with interest to declare should
refer to the gender item and describe
the nature of their interests when the
item is being considered
elected members of denver county council
and town parish councils
who've considered a plumbing application
by virtue of the membership of that
council called a personal interest
and are deemed to have considered the
application separately
and the expressed views of that council
do not find the members concerned and
considered the application of fresh
item four on the agenda is agreements
between parts one and two there are no
part there is no part two of this agenda
item five urgent matters i've nothing
no urgent matters
item six is public participation we've
got
one two three four five six members of
the public or six members
speaking
there's russell smith from walting and
planning speaking in support of
the atlantic cleveland south of
cleveland
council langford has sent an email in
which we read it by the planning manager
the board member
and
then petruck still kate smith speaking
against a member of the public
malcolm buster against
but he sent a letter in that will be
read out by planning managers
and councillor hermet is here as ward
member to speak and then land at
manchester the nammer
angus cook from demetrius holmes
manager of devonshire horns is here to
speak in support of the application
okay we move on item seven is planning
applications
the information
recommendations and advice contained in
the reports
are correct as a the date of preparation
which is more than 10 days in advance of
the committee meeting
due to these time constraints any
changes or necessary updates to the
reports
will be provided in writing or orally at
the committee meeting
so then we move on
to 7a our first application
this morning which is on
pages 19
to 50 of your agenda
and planning planning opposite christie
to present this one thank you
thank you chad um so firstly um just a
couple updates so there's been two new
objections uh one relates to highways
the other relates mainly to smell
and noise distance
[Music]
mix
and i'll touch on those later on again
[Music]
[Music]
so this is um phase one um
you can see the outline site red there
next slide
and there's there are photos
[Music]
um is for the north side is uh
the
existing entrance to the west
and the existing entrance in the east
this is within that gateway that i wish
we're standing from by looking at high
park farm that they have which was
subject to debate uh last wednesday
[Music]
interesting
um
you across the site have inside this
convertible so you can see this
concludes the phase one and
phase two and science is
[Music]
would actually fly in the background
southwest corner of the side and as we
travel up the hill
if you're looking towards the north west
corner of the side
[Music]
northwest
[Music]
background
[Music]
there's a number of new trees added
above the available school area and then
other locations on the side there's also
additional tree screening
which
is an addition to what we said before
and there's also
[Music]
so this is the other section size 2
large shell on the side but that shows
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
and these character areas as there's
three characteristics uh
so the main uh industry
solidity of green edge
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
so
um
and this one shows materials the science
search
clearly shows
varied materials
and with a fairly straight seam as a
result
let's cycle these
and this is
[Music]
this
[Music]
next time
[Music]
this shows the um
stock effects that will travel
uh
throughout the southern boundary side
across the protection area
um
[Music]
be delivered using vcc one and six funds
um so it would like the existing tube to
put away uh which is on
the
side
and that's the tree in the headset
that approval subject condition
um
members have debated this in some detail
last night
um it was the third the reason for a
very worst even minutes um was to
address
the discussions last time
so
briefly quickly go through what those
were as for the minutes
and then
back to the chair
um
last time there was a discussion
on smell
so um in my opinion the smell
isn't a consideration for this
application
even if it were the nearest dwelling to
the main
barn at high park farm is 250 meters
away and environmental protection do not
have any
uh issues going smack in these
highways again not a consideration
however
um
that can have provided some additional
details
just it remembers some
um
peace of mind i suppose but they're not
actually part of that fish attack
because
those details included
information about the traffic regulation
of borders
and information about potential site
crossing which included
island and fabulise
and
and sweatpart analysis for a capital
trailer
but again
um um section 106 complications um was
discussed in some detail last time um
again it's not something we can revisit
and if i can quickly ask tell him to
drop back to the site location plan i
think they might use to explain one
thing though
um
actually sorry the sitemap today
yeah maybe go back onto the next one
yeah that would be great so
there is um
initially within the policy as you see
my report the
playing fields were supposed to be at
the flat areas
[Music]
and i was as a result of the mitigation
required by hyper farm um
in parts of the mitigation strategy
they've
pushed all the times as far as possible
um which
is advisable um
so the dwellings are now in the
policy requires
the application space
and the playing field
so there is now a playing field proposed
where some point of design
[Music]
is not possible to provide full size
play
pitch and so they happen to come into a
deeper variation which again uh members
were made with last time
the variation takes up
[Music]
difference in
[Music]
when there's no longer an adult
statistician that's a new size pitch so
there's the financial contribution
proposed
that financial contribution is to secure
improved sports pictures elsewhere
within a very good area and it includes
487 pounds
and generated
maintenance cost of 56 thousand pounds
so
that that's the legal variation
as part of this recommendation i
recommend that if members are money to
prove that a decision
is effectively
not issued until they can sign up to
that variation because
they can't provide that pitch elsewhere
on the side so
we need the money
does that make sense yeah
so that's that's the section one of the
states important but there's no
provision for us to bury the model so
faster varying the highways money that
people's already secured et cetera that
just isn't a provision so
that's my consideration
um
so that's now highways section 6 that
will
amendments to the plan as as previously
indicated
include official trees and
additional
[Music]
events and there's also been a
non-technical summary regarding noise
which hopefully members have seen um
it doesn't really add anything to what
was there but it provides in
famous terms
mr
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
so in our opinion um
does not necessarily have to be applied
rigidly that's indicated in their uh
natural planetary violence
in any event
the way in which this scheme has been
designed
and the way in which the pre-op
discussions have taken place
the acoustic design statement what that
effect does is it requires
a primary approach being utilized so
this is what the investigation is
if you can't believe that
yes you can't allow it to do this
and that's what's being followed here so
it's clear why for example the acoustic
screen would work um
obviously it's just really steep all
right
it's cheering on sorry to introduce the
point of order um the letter from this
is i've not seen this letter
it was email around here though i've not
been thinking
by now he's been
yes so i'll let you read that but it's
um it's effectively just an additional
objection so this added
so that effectively say
why
why it's okay and
so you've got a hierarchical approach in
our opinion even though an abs has not
been submitted it's not a requirement
under policy and
the principles of how this scheme has
been designed
at the same
really as what the abs would
the outcome would have been and
discuss that late days
[Music]
[Music]
for the previous meeting so
all plans committee members are um
familiar with this site we have a
detailed site visit a virtual site visit
this
so
and
councillor mcgoff just brought it that
he's not seen
the solicitor's letter that came on
behalf of the hot ridge family from the
farm
also at the same time email ram was a
briefing note from waltzing and
planning yeah i don't know if you've
seen that
it was email around to everybody
and and also there are a couple of other
documents that were also emailed around
from
that to do with uh the application to do
with the noise attenuation scheme
proposed but we'll get into that
discussion of it
on this because i've not received any of
the information because obviously it's
been bad for me so i you know this
informed you really to vote for or again
cyber liberty
and not take part in
well they more or less say what chris
has just alluded to in his presentation
anyway
right okay we'll we're bringing the
first the first speaker is
um
russell smith from waltzing and planning
his speaking in support once you settle
you've got
three more thank you
two minutes are committed okay
see if i can keep
good morning mr chairman and members of
the community since the previous
committee additional information has
been submitted to in response to members
concerns
including a non-technical noise
mitigation summary and additional
highway plans
the applicant also sends across a
briefing note to members
on monday we wish to use this speech to
highlight the key points from this
firstly it is important to remember that
the application for you only seeks
approval for those matters reserved by
outline planning commission uh
layout scale appearance and landscape
matters related to the principle of the
development and access are not open for
consideration
never nevertheless the applicant has
provided additional information
uh which goes beyond the scope of the
reserve matters to provide clarity and
comfort to members
in terms of noise from high park farm
the effect of high park pharma
development has been a central
consideration throughout the outlying
and reserve mass process
the applicants follow the noise
mitigation hierarchy proposed an agreed
outline stage
the layout provides separation from the
noise source
and dwellings uh from the noise source
of dwellings
uh acoustic screening the buildings have
been considered but its effectiveness is
limited due to the site typography
bedrooms have been located on the north
side of the dwellings where practicable
and mechanical ventilation is provided
where required
the submitted noise mitigation scheme
put forward is fully compliant with the
noise mitigation options agreed at
outline stage and will ensure desirable
nighttime noise levels for all houses
therefore complying with condition 14 of
the outmarket permission
this has been accepted by officers and
the environmental protection officer and
is based upon empirical independently
verifiable evidence
mechanical ventilation is included for
bedrooms and some dwellings we would
like to assure members
that this does not prevent residents
from opening windows and will not result
in overheating
or the need for air conditioning
and it maintains a comfortable
temperature during the night time and
it's designed
to maintain that temperature as if a
window is open
and it provides flexibility for
residents to open windows for purge
ventilation or if they wish
furthermore it uses low energy and
indeed it will be a mandatory
requirement for new developments when
new overheating building regulations
take effect later this month
the circumstances this application also
differ markedly from the chichester
appeal cited by the solicitors in the uh
electricity score stacked on behalf of
hyde park farm
in that case mechanical ventilation
would have been required for all
habitable rooms during the daytime as
well as night time to ensure acceptable
standards that is not the case with this
application mitigation is only required
for bedrooms at night time
and even without that mitigation
noise levels will still be within that
which is considered to be reasonable
levels
during the night time
in response to members concerns
regarding enclosure of the farm revised
landscape details have been submitted
that would provide stock proof fence and
strength of planting
in terms of odor from the farm this
matter has been considered our
allocation outline stage and fact to be
acceptable and that's based upon
independently verifiable laboratory
testing
could you how should you weigh in yes so
the last reserve master has been told to
maintain separation distance from the
farm and the ego is satisfied the odor
is not likely to cause a saturations
closure of this will have road is not
automatic for consideration part of this
application um the application will not
prejudice the separate statutory process
however additional plans demonstrate the
layout of highway being designed to
accommodate agricultural traffic and uh
suitable noise mitigation provided for
the houses fronting the road
in terms of delivery of the school this
was secured in the section 106 at
outline stage and final decision
wrestled with pcc and in terms of
section 106 contributions these were
agreed outline planning stage and what's
not not part of the reserve matters
application fisher's providing
illustrated crossing detail that can
ensure safety second activities through
this cycle side of the north i'm
grateful for your time and ask you to
support today's recommendations and i'm
available along with representatives of
fishery homes to answer any questions
should members have questions thank you
right the next uh
is from councillor langford an email
we'll tell them we'll read it
apologies but i cannot attend today's
meeting as you will recall i spoke at
the last meeting when this application
was discussed i would just like it noted
that my concerns remain the same the
proximity of the houses to the farm is
an issue in terms of noise and smell i
am particularly worried about farm
vehicles being routed through the estate
and i did not feel confident after the
last meeting that this would not be the
case thank you
thank you
right now it's open for discussion and
we really have to come to a decision
this morning on this application we
decided
last time for certain things to be
fleshed out more and for those who've
not seen
the emails that came around on monday
they
there were documents there was also a
non-tech technical summary from
fistfield
and also although it's not part of it
because we raise the issue about
crossing the clovelly road
they've also applied to
a ttro traffic regulation order
applications with the county council in
consideration
to propose a change to the speed limit
along cleveland road to 30 miles an hour
which would be according to the plan in
the year from almost abbott's across
roundabout it would be 30 miles an hour
from there
so
and also they have addressed
the boundary with uh high part farm
they're going to put stockproof fence in
there and increase the planting along
there
which will help with the acoustic when
you see when we are reminded from the
photographs
you can see how steep that site is and
even with the school site
the housing further up
is why acoustic fencing wouldn't have
any
manageable effect on
[Music]
[Music]
yeah um right i kicked off then i mean i
was pleased to see that there's nothing
really fenced
in the boundary of high park farms an
additional plan was taking place and as
the chairs just said although it's not
part of this application they the
applicant did take into consideration
um how concerned about the pedestrian
crossing and they're in negotiating with
highways they're like that and bringing
down the
speed limit along cleveland road to 30
miles an hour
and i was pleased to read the
non-technical noise mitigation summary
which made everything a lot clearer
um
and in the first noise assessment it
also said that the estate would be
exposed to other noise sources eg road
traffic atlantic park and from the
industrial estate as well as the farm so
the farm wasn't the only
noise problem
we as the chairs just eluded we received
this letter from richard buxton and i
was going to ask the officer about
points 14 and 15 about the adf but i
think the officer is satisfactory
explained all that
um
[Music]
so
with regards to the smells um
[Music]
i know we've got uh our office here this
morning our environmental protection
officer but i mean noise and smells from
farms are all part of rural life
and when violence bled spread slurry and
dirty water baby smelled from many miles
around and not even come from this
particular farm i mean on many occasions
i've been in biddeford and you see
tractors and slurry spreaders behind
coming in from all directions in bigfoot
and leave in all directions from benefit
and i mean contractors travel miles to
spread slurry and lots and lots of
farmers have got off ground so you know
you shouldn't be just thinking that the
smell is just going to come from my part
farm and also modern spreaders inject
the material straight into the ground so
this negates a lot of the smell anyway
so i am going to propose that the
recommended
the application is approved as per the
officer's recommendations
thank you counselor
competitor
council like i said i was going to say
anyway um but um with regards to the
boundary that's one of the concerns i
have um obviously i was one that voted
against the last time i sort of given
considerable thought to this
with regard to the sound and smell i
really you know speaking as a dairy
farmer i think this has been somewhat
overstated to be absolutely honest
um a good well-managed dairy farm
doesn't smell nor does it make excessive
noise then to be honest
they've got a very successful milk
vending machine there and if that farm
smells people wouldn't go and buy the
milk so it can't be a serious problem
and as council locks said most of the
smell actually comes from the field
where slow is being spread not from the
actual farm itself
um i mean i'm unfortunate i don't have
200 houses next to my farm but i do have
eight dwellings within less than that
distance
and you know although i mean quite a few
some of those are people who move from
away some are local people i'm quite
sure that if i was persistently creating
such smell and noise that they couldn't
sleep at night i think somebody would
have said something like that
so um you know i really
you know i don't think that's a valid
diagram so
um i hate to see
wonderful land being covered in houses
but there's nothing i can do about that
so reluctantly i'm going to have to vote
to support it
council watson and then council
christian yeah i i totally agree with
what both of you just said
i i live in very very rural i'm
surrounded by farms actually
and if the room wins in one direction
then changes coming up i still get the
smell but that's part of the parcel of
living in the countryside um well i did
notice actually
is that um
765
um
letters were sent out to
the neighbors only 14 managed to come
back
you know and and only nine objected
so
i if wrote i think rosa proposed that we
we approved this and i'll second it
okay
thank you council boxing council
christie
thank you um
i'm gonna touch on some points i haven't
already been touched on um
first of all the school
i hear again the school has been you
know the land has been set aside
i did ask and uh our late planning
manager the last one
did actually send us this is this from
devon county outlining the numbers of
children
that can be generated from this school
whether they need new school or where to
go
i i actually went through this
it's an insult to your intelligence
it's incredible the they say that i
could breathe out um delivery of the new
school has been determined by the
housing build out an increased need in
the area for additional school places
and they say the proposed build out 60
to 70 plants per year on the south of
the roadside means an additional 15 to
18 primary school children per year
they've ignored 750 houses in the north
of this site there's another 50 houses
at least on small sites in western
um 800 houses you're talking about an
extra
number of children
far in excess of the figures that devon
county seems to be working on
and it comes to what
why i'm bringing this up is that
this
development is a classic example of a
lack of joined up thinking
we know we have a nearly new school and
yet we still don't seem to know where
it's going to be what's going to happen
we need to know that beforehand again i
read through all the planning
applications nothing here at all
about new health centers for benefit and
yet that anyone who lives in benefit
will know that's one of the main
constituents problems that they always
tell you about
again
i did warn you i'm gonna bring this up
every time now sewage i understand as a
pumping plant on this side
pump it away and forget about it
cornbread we don't know what the
carrying capacity of cornbread is we had
a long discussion only a few days ago
about sewage
and we still don't know where the
cornbread can actually
take this sewage and yet we've glidely
it planned a mission for another you
know 485 houses on this whole site and
nobody seems to look at this this is why
i'm expressing this lack of joint up
thinking again you go back to the roads
i'm told that the developers are now
having a conversation about a possible
30 miles an hour living
that's nonsense
if you're going to have a load of
children here you've got to cross the
road from one side to the other
you know 30 miles an hour with no
crossing point
although i was out of meeting um
i think it was
last week uh matt collins i don't know
if we've got anybody from devon county
here this morning
but matt collins was actually talking
about the crossing
yeah along this road
and i i don't know where that's gone i
mean 30 miles an hour
and it's this lack of joined up thinking
we're not looking at the whole picture
we're looking at just one estate and
everyone says well these problems but
it's not looking at the future of
business
and i'm afraid i can't vote for this
i'm at the end of my tether with you
thank you
thank you councillor christie
well as far as the school sites i mean i
i've got some simply because i thought
that um response right we had from devon
county council that sean harrington sent
around us all was it was an insult
because
they guesstimate the
demographics into the future and they
reckon there's not going to be
increasing basically there won't be much
of an increase in children
but as far as this site's concerned
the applicant and the developer has to
provide a cyber school and that's
they've done that on this side so we
can't argue
that they're not fulfilling what they're
obliged to do in this application there
is a site for a school that whether it
is built there eventually or on the
other side of colorado is out of that
developer's house that's down to the
county council
but i just wish that they would
definitely say
datton hill is the same over behind baby
road
tell us a date you're going to start
building that school once these sites
are available
so i do have a lot of sympathy on that
school
i'm more
[Music]
there's the one thing i'm still
not quite happy about and chris
mentioned it is the clay provisional the
this site's big enough to have a proper
full size pitch but for the reasons
uh that chris alluded to directly they
can't fit one on this side i was at a
site that size and i know the topography
is an issue but
for for the money to be spent elsewhere
in benefit
i just hope it doesn't disappear and
it's just used to enhance victoria park
or whatever there should be proper
sports pictures this council's
been very poor over the years in
providing proper sport stretches in the
area but that's uh that's a different
one
if nobody else is wanting to contribute
and
i'm a bit i'm a bit happier than i was
at the last month from all of this oh
it's been proposed by councilman
certainly by councillor watson that we
approved this application sander would
you take the vote please yes thank you
chair councillor benton for chancellor
brown for chancellor christie
councillor craigie yes
councillor london four
councillor for all
that's six four chair two against one
abstention
okay if we move on then
next application is on
[Music]
channel
the next application on pages 51-69
[Music]
two and a half years ago
[Music]
so i think you know um
taking all that into account and advice
i've taken and so forth i think that if
i can come here with a clear open mind
and i'm looking forward to getting off
this day
thank you to that counselor
right uh sarah boy our planning
obviously will give us a presentation on
this thank you sarah okay
thank you very much so as um
councilman has mentioned um he is the
board member and this was called in but
it was called in as a member of the
plans committee and the reason was um
to basically discuss the development as
it involves the loss of a community
service as per policy st 22
so the application is for the change of
use from a mixed use of public house and
dwelling to a solely private dwelling
so this is um
the location plan and you might
recognize it from a couple of committees
ago um we had an application to the
south for some armed houses um
so the pub is in red and just to kind of
give you a bit of a kind of context of
it it is quite central to petrol stone
um to the north you've got the village
hall as i said to the south you've got
the arms houses and the listed memorial
to the east you've got some listed
cottages and then to the west you've got
the grade 2 star church
this is a block plan just kind of
zooming in a little bit so the building
subject was the proposal was pointed out
to you you've got the parking and
highways there to the north um and it
just points out the church and war
memorial
so just to go on to some some photos so
this is the the public house itself um
when the site visit was undertaken the
public house had already closed that was
in september 2021 um
this is just to show you a bit of
context so this is looking um kind of
southward so you've got the proposed ax
the access and parking for the pub
and that's what's to propose to use for
the dwelling as well then you've got the
listed cottages um
to the east
this is just a kind of close-up of the
pub itself
this is just showing you from a
different angle the the car park um that
is proposed to be used for this
application and was also proposed to be
used for the arms houses as well
next slide
so yeah this is just looking northwoods
to give you a bit of context so that's
the arms houses the church um in the
background the memorial in the
foreground and then you've got the
church and then you can just kind of see
baxter hall which is the village hall as
well
so it's just showing that obviously it
was um kind of posted on the pub that it
had been closed um from the the 18th of
september 2021.
this is just to show you kind of a bit
more of the parking so there's roughly
kind of 10 to 12 spaces in the car park
the next slide just shows the same with
kind of the retaining wall with the
church behind it
and then the next side does show kind of
the church in full view um from the car
park itself
this is just kind of a closer look from
the arms houses they are joined um so
they're not they're not separate um so
this is it's looking north
[Music]
and the next one is just showing the the
pub setting the ground to the front of
the pub and the arms houses and and the
church and the road
[Music]
these are just to clearly show you the
proposed alternatives that have been put
forward um in terms of um kind of if the
public house was lost the alternatives
provided
so the first is baxter
hall which is the village hall that has
parking um within the report obviously
i've gone into more detail about the
alternatives but let's just show you
some imagery
if we just go to the next slide that's
just to show that there is kind of a
play park within the village hall
vicinity
and then the next one you can see kind
of in the background there this is the
cricket pavilion this was the other
alternative this is just under two
kilometers from the public house it's
outside the main built form of petrox
stone
so this is just to show you the the
structure itself
and then we've just got a few more kind
of closer ones just to show you that it
is completely
um it is open-sided um so it's not
contained and then the next slide is
just to show kind of the
layout that they have got um
just to
kind of show you the the alternatives so
the next is the floor plan so there are
no internal proposed works um and
there's no external proposed works um
for this application it is just looking
at the the change of use of the building
and then this is just to show you what
the current sales page on a property
website is for um the application
because obviously within the report
there has been mention about the value
of the the property and what it's being
marketed at
so just to say obviously the main
planning considerations
are the principle of development so the
report has gone through policy st07 um
we have looked at five-year housing land
supply in terms of the tilted balance
and also policy st22 which is looking at
the loss of the community
facility
we then go on to impact on character and
appearance in the listed buildings
then we've got impact on residential
amenities
access and parking drainage and ecology
and considering the tilted balance it
has come to a recommendation of refusal
thank you sarah
you've got
the first speaker for this is a member
of the public speaking against
which is kate smith
welcome i'm roger settle you've got
three minutes
to address the committee thank you good
morning good morning i've lived in peck
rockstar for over 19 years and went to
the pub two to three times a week
the laurels has always been at the
center of this thriving friendly village
it was well loved well-used with an
excellent reputation
a pub is classified as a community
facility this formal term doesn't
express what belongs means to us
it's a place for social interaction
meeting new people and old friends it's
vital in an isolated village for
supporting mental health and combating
loneliness
it can provide that first job for
youngsters and benefits local trades
it's a place to brainstorm fundraising
and recruit volunteers
it hosts christening's birthdays
weddings anniversaries and final
farewells
the national planning policy framework
makes it clear that the retention of
such facilities should be promoted
the prices argue the pub isn't
commercially viable
under its current ownership that may be
the case sadly it seems the demeanor of
the proprietors and lack of quality food
has turned people away
there is no doubt that in the care of
enthusiastic knowledgeable
and hardworking owners with publicly
viable
there is so much potential for the
laurels to once
again become a success
it's the only pub in the village with
many pride and holiday let's
new developments have been approved
we're close to trail the pub has pulled
darts skittles and crooked teams the
monthly quiz was always well attended
during the shooting season guns and
beaters are regular visitors
pub has potential for b and b and with
the adjoining arms houses potential for
a shock post office or both
the inability of one landlord to turn a
profit doesn't mean the laurels isn't
commercially viable
there is no alternative provision
accessible by walking or cycling the
village hall is just that it's not
comparable to a pub it's run by
volunteers so to expect them to replace
what a pub offers is ludicrous
the local sports club referred to as an
open sided shed with no floor in the
middle of a field one mile from the
village no footpaths or street lighting
if you take the time to go you'll
normally find someone walking their dog
not enjoying a pint and company or
friends the applicants argue that the
pub is no longer required to meet the
needs of the local community
surely 139 letters of objection shall we
require this poll
their statement also refers to the
inability of the current owners to sell
the pub as a going concern
several pubs have sold recently in the
surrounding villages
is it because the lord is overpriced
and why is the property that received no
offers increased in price by 15 000
pounds
laura's is our only pub the planning is
permitted for it to be changed into just
another house that will never come back
the community will be lessened without
it
surely the council cannot disregard this
potential community facility in favor of
a short current term gain for its
current owners
thank you
thank you for that very good timing that
was interesting
okay the next speaker is well it's a
letter
helen mourinho from malcolm
my name is malcolm busby i am the
chairman of the parish council and the
chairman of the village hall trustees
and a proud parishioner of petrol state
pedrock stone is a friendly and
compassionate village contrary to what
has been said in the planning
application
the pub is the center and heart of the
village where people can meet whether as
a couple family or individual on most
days of the week no need to make an
appointment just go up to the pub and
there will be someone you know for those
in the village who live on their own it
is a lifeline
much has been made in the application
that the village has a village all but
that serves a different purpose which is
home to various clubs and groups and
events are held there occasionally but
it is not open every day you cannot just
pop in it is a charity and cannot be run
as a pub it would be against charity
commission rules
for many years the hall worked closely
with the pub to mutual benefit
when i moved to the village
as with many others a pub within walking
distance was on the wish list
and many of the visitors to the village
who stay in accommodation in and around
the village come because the village has
a pub
there is a great plan for over 20 houses
in the village on many of the
applications and subsequent
comments by the planning committee a
thriving pub was mentioned as an asset
of the village indeed it is
the pub was and can be a profitable
business under the local plan policy st
22 which states that any development
that involves the loss of community
services and facilities will not be
supported unless there is compelling
evidence to demonstrate three things
the existing use is no longer viable
there is alternative local provision
within walking or cycling distance
the premises are no longer required to
meet the needs of the local community
none of these are applicable the pub is
viable there is no alternative and it is
needed to meet the needs of the
community
there seems to be very little effort to
sell the purpose of going concern
indeed the price of 450 000 has priced
it out of the market and this has been
confirmed by the valuation done by the
db in their report form
point one i i say and i quote the
evidence available suggests that the
latest asking price for the property of
450 000 is too high
they also stay in the same section and i
quote again i am off the view that
despite the pub closing the subject
property does have potential as a
trading entity and i'm off the view that
a reasonably efficient operator would be
interested in running it
we do not have many facilities in the
village do not take our pub away from us
particularly now as we are we are coming
out of covered the pub is needed more
than ever as people start socializing
again it will help to bring the
community together again which is also a
great way for the new people in the
village to meet and make friends
next speaker to this application is the
agent for the applicant
[Music]
thank you thank you if you just give
your name please my name is john gower
i'm the agent for the applicant
um and i'm sort of my
request to speak with some traps by
easyjet
welcome back till this week thank you
very much one second you've got three
minutes to address the committee thank
you thank you members of the committee
thank you mr chairman um i've only got a
few points to raise
um
[Music]
we've read the report
the applicants i was i was instructed by
the applicants to
apply for this permission
to
change which is already a dwelling but
one of the rooms downstairs is a pub it
was dwelling before it was a pub in the
70s one of the rooms downstairs became a
public house
so
the applicants live there and continue
to live there they don't need permission
to out there it is a dwelling
but
the pub wasn't viable the accounts have
shown it's not viable the paperwork's
showing the number of weeks in a year
that the beer has to be returned to the
brewery show it's not viable the number
of people even with track and trace
we're able to see
how few people actually use the pub
there's no dispute that a pub is a great
thing to have in a village that people
want the pub to be there
um
for the people that use it it's a nice
thing to have
but you can't run a business that
doesn't that loses
a ton of money every month
um
one of the things that we noted in the
report was
that the council was asked to assess
whether it was an asset of community
value
a report was done during uh
application period
and it assessed all the alternative
venues as it must do
and it said that it was not
an asset of community value and that was
it that was legal finding the report
that report set out that the baxter hall
was able to operate with a license
in a flexible way without the overheads
of the
the staffing costs
[Music]
and was the hub of the community that
was the asset of community value
we were asked originally to
make this application
simply to make the pub more marketable
because those have expressed an interest
in buying the pub have said they won't
do so
without some sort of security or
fallback they're interested in running
the pub but they want to know that if
the pub
can't continue in a viable manner that
they are able to have it as a dwelling
house
so we were asked to make the application
the
applicants would love to sell it as a
pub
um they've tried for several years
they've had offers um pre-coded
an offer of 400 000 was accepted
solicitors were engaged and then the
pandemic
in terms of policy
we're not quite clear on the housing
policy references in the um
in the offices report because this is
not a proposal for a new dwelling there
is already a dwelling in the building
the lack of viability we say is
demonstrated by the paperwork clearly
it was marketed at 12 months at a
sensible price
the offer of slightly in excess of the
asking price was proof of that
um
and it was
had been on the market for 12 months
[Music]
and the only thing that we wanted to
make clear was that
and it's not and it's been found by this
council not to be an asset of community
value um
we don't feel that um
there's any
there's any justifiable reason to
turn down the application when it can be
used as a dwelling in any case will
continue to be it isn't open it isn't
operating it won't be reopened
um
because
the owners are losing money too
it will remain a dwelling um unless it
can be solved and this was a way of
trying to make it simple
thank you very much for your time thank
you
and finally ward member councilman
good morning
um when i hear people talking about
moving into another area or we would
like to see relocating produce on tv
and they would like to live in a rural
village
one criteria should be more popular than
any other
that criteria
criteria is that there should be a pub
hopefully within walking distance of the
new home where new friends can be made
the new social life will be forged
the pub is the main draw
and is often at the hub of the village
as is the case in the application before
you
having read through the documents
associated with this application
i was struck by the number of
representations
registered with torridge 103
representations were submitted to which
139 were objections
three were in support and it was the
application and one was neutral
these are numbers i normally associate
with unpopular
large-scale development proposals and i
believe that this shows not only the
strength of opposition to this
application
but also how important the pub is to
local people
in fact it's reported that when this
application is discussed at the parish
council meeting
held in november 2021
more parishioners had attended any other
pc meeting of recent times and it was
stated that nobody meeting was in favor
of the change of use proposal
the agent rated several points in the
application in favor of change of use of
the property
the parish council
and indeed others in their objection
comments refute many of these points
i believe the principle one is where
it's stated and i quote
there is alternative local provision and
in fact the popularity of this local
provision may well be one of the reasons
the public house is no longer used or
effectively needed by the local
community
well you've heard already about a couple
of places in petrol so one being the uh
the cricket area club down there
open-sided a long way from the village
effectively dark lanes certainly not
suitable enlightenment
this alternative and local provision
refers to the village hall and the
parish council response by consulting
comment number four
clearly debunks this view when it states
and i quote there is certainly no
competition between the two venues and
the village hall does not offer a
licensed food and drink option other
than for a limited number of specific
events
in the three years prior to comet 2017
18 and 19
the viviz in the consulting response for
events taking place in the beach
which
showed that 45 events took place
during that time including four private
events needing an average of one per
three weeks over that time scale
hardly an alternative provision
this in my view certainly doesn't
compare in any way you've been able to
pop into a pub either to meet friends
or off the channel on the off chance
someone you know may already be in them
this is obviously not possible in the
village hall that is closed for most of
the time apart from when local village
groups started using it during the day
in addition events are held at the
village hall
where it would cost impossible for the
pub to host examples in the consulting
response take dance evenings and brass
and silver band events
i'm not going to go into other issues
including such as marketing or pricing
the officer's committee report covers
these issues and i'm sure you're
familiar with them
i'll come back over to the point i made
earlier about the pub being the hub of
the community
who darts and skittle teams were based
at the pub
residents were at one time able to
gather to watch rugby
which i understand was a hugely popular
community
event i understand the financial aspect
of running a pub in these modern times
can be challenging however with
enthusiastic management and the support
of local residents as appears to be
clearly the case here
i believe it's possible to run a
thriving and profitable business
i'll close by saying that the popular
and vibrant pub
is a key element in a happy and
inclusive village but once a pub is
closed
it is very unlikely to return and as an
asset of convenience and value was lost
thank you thank you thank you councillor
hurley
all right that's the last of the
speakers council wiseman thank you chair
for let me start um yes we all know i
called this in the reason being quite
simple that this is obviously an
application with huge amount of public
interest
and that's i think it's important that
that kind of
application gets the decision gets made
in a public forum where people see the
decision being made
and also
um the public out there opportunity to
state their case and so forth because i
think they've done very well
um just a very good report again
the parish council made a very lengthy
reply i don't think i've ever seen one
as long as that
they put a clearly put a great deal of
consideration into it and i'm very glad
that the officer got the district's
value up
um
because that seems to be fundamental to
the whole
the whole issue um
people have got about a lot to say about
the local land but i think the local
plan as far as this kind of application
goes it's got its spot on
there has to be
compelling evidence that pub is unviable
i i don't see that evidence in this
report
the district value work doesn't give us
that evidence in fact he said
it is a marvel business
um
landlords come and landlords go some are
very efficient make money others might
lose planning but that honestly doesn't
mean that
it's on fire
um i i could go on and on but i think
i'll leave uh i'll leave the opportunity
for other committee members to speak
thank you
council
yeah
off by um that i
used to use the pub and the village hall
at recklesstown but i've been in the pub
for at least eight nine ten years so i
can't declare an open mind um
we often comment about parish councils
not making any comments my entirely
agreeing captain wiseman i've never seen
such a long response from a parish
council in all my ten years on the
planets we've seen albeit um
a lot of it was material considerations
but it was all instant information
um and i'm always banging on about every
application on its own merits but if you
cast your minds back recently the credo
calms at little was refused planning
permission for change of use and they
lost that on appeal
and also likewise the coaching was about
the brewer they tried for change of use
but that was refused and they were both
the only pups in the village
um and again i agree with council
wiseman that the district values report
and this is key wording to me he says
um
as a trade in equity i am of the view
that a reasonably efficient operator
would be interested in running it and
the additional rooms actually offer the
potential to add to the business
so i think that's the most important
statement from the district valuer so i
will propose that the application is
refused
thank you council councilwoman
your second council wiseman
yep no well when i when i read through
it i thought
exactly what council locks just said
the district value it is about it can be
made to be a viable viable business
but if you look at the proposal it does
say
change of use from a mixed use of public
house and private development to solder
a private dwelling so if this was
improved it would certainly be dwelling
it wouldn't be a problem with it
with accommodation with living
accommodation
it isn't it is a dwelling now because
it's a problem with
living accommodations is what it is
but but it is valuable to the i agree
with all the parish council upset in
here
it is a valuable asset to the community
probably with a new landlord and it
would be
profitable again and be a big success in
the community anybody else want to say
anything on this one
i'll just add to that but
and i mean i'm very fortunate in
property we've got an excellent well
pump and i mean that is the key it's the
people that are running the pub and
actually speaking to them they're
actually busier now than they were
pre-coded
so you know that
makes points if it's well-run there's no
reason why it can't be successful my
only concern is is that
um
the public i don't know there's nothing
we can do as my plans committee but
they're just going to sort of hang on to
this aren't they because they're not
going to sell it they're just going to
sort of try and drag it along but
there's maybe as much people don't
suppose but yeah and that's the problem
is that these posts there
they're still being run and open but the
trouble is the owners have got the house
bit so it's just going downhill but
there's
nobody else wants to contribute to this
so it's been proposed uh that council
locked sentenced by councillor wiseman
or cancer christie or cancer craigie or
cancer leather for counselling for
counselling mcgrath or cancer watson or
taxler wiseman more unanimous to refuse
chad
james
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
this is just to help
[Music]
right you'll see this application is on
pages
so i make it 69
to 76
in your agenda
and
james jackson
our planning officer will give us a
presentation i know it seems a bit hard
and i'll explain my reasons on this
at the end of the presentation
thanks sir yeah thank you can everyone
hear me okay yeah
okay so good morning everyone um
says this is
application one slash triple zero five
slash twenty twenty two slash nmat
as a non-material moment proposed
planning commission uh one slasher five
[Music]
where the brazilian monsters came for
committee last november on the 5th of
november
um
it was a reserved master's approval for
225 dwellings up at montana way
but that was a resolution to grant by by
this committee um and accordingly we we
granted plane commission a couple of
days after
um the the application now before
committee is a non-material amendment to
that except mission
uh next slide please done
uh and non-material amendments are
made possible by section 96a of the
italian country planning act
um
and that allows non-material changes to
be made to a proposal that already has
planning permission
and the key really as this slide shows
is that the the government's
um
planning practice guidance ppg advises
that there's no definition of what is
non-material or material
and the key really is that it's always
about context as with many things in in
planning and judgment for the decision
maker to be made
whether those changes are
indeed non-material or in fact
material and so because of the the
reference to contacts there really in
the in the ppg it's necessary to have
um
in
in the minds of committee to have
um regard for what's been permitted
before really and the scale of that
proposal and the various elements to
that proposal committed last november
next slide please
so this lists the proposed amendments
and if the plan that i just handed out
is basically an overview of these
amendments
what's on the screen now corresponds
broadly with what's on the bottom left
hand side of your plan
those those uh amendments are obviously
numbered and then the numbering there
corresponds with
what's shown on the individual plots
ie so you can see number one is plots
changed to stone coins added
etc etc and
and there's two clocks that that relates
to on the planet showing the number one
on those plots
in the main um
the amendments one to five are
minor design changes to various house
types
um
the proposed amendment number six is a
very minor layout change to four clocks
which are
blocks 24 27
um 24 through 27 up by the lead
up by the northern boundary
uh
changes seven to 13 again the various
minor design changes to
various house types
and the change is 14 and 50 in the
boundary treatment changes um in terms
of
the
previously committed
stone walls
so i'll just take you briefly through
each of those um each of those proposed
amendments
uh next slightly done
so here you can see
this is proposed change number one the
house type at the
top is what we've is what committee have
approved previously
and um what is now proposed is shown at
the bottom
and looks like this home
uh this on the on the left hand side is
what has been previously committed on
the right hand side as no one's proposed
um
changed to the group type from a gay
belong to a hip 10 and uh coins added on
the form of the plot there and some
minor changes to the detail and on the
on the canopy as well looks like please
tell them
uh again what we've previously committed
is on the top that's the bitly the
modbury and the saunt and house types go
left to right now what's proposed is is
shown on the bottom there
and the rounded reveals are quite
difficult to show on a drawing basically
um but what it is is effectively where
actually when window reveals are they're
just slightly more rounded rather than
having a
crisp sharp edge to them
and you can see obviously the timber
lintels to the ground floor
windows on the box
and it's likely tone
uh this pro on the left hand side is
what we've um previously has been
permitted and on the right hand side is
what's going on proposed
again minor detailing changes
and next slide please sign
again
this is um from the top the saunton
bickley and moderate going left to right
and the top is what's been previously
approved now the bottom is what goes on
this is the only layout change that's
proposed so this is
four plots this is up just to the to the
west of the the leap um you can see it's
a slight rotation of blocks 24 25 26 27
and just reorganization of the car
parking around those plots
uh next likely so
this is
just the
end gables uh on the rendered box
they're now to be proposed as as brick
with coins
it's likely selling
and this is the
this is the example of the heartland
dwelling it's also proposed on the
bitcoin dwelling and the affordable
dwellings
which is
what we've previously approved on the
left-hand side and what's now proposed
on the right-hand side
a next slide recently
again previously approved on the left
hand side and the um
now proposed on the right hand side
next slide please
and again this is on the dwelling type
of part
previously approved on the left and the
now proposed on the right
side
and again so the
um the upper
the
drawings there are what's previously
improved and then the lower
is what's now proposed i've just
included the rear elevation there as
well so there is a change on the rear
elevation of
that property as proposed
which is effectively a chicken which is
that small gable feature
roofliner and an additional window as
well
next slide please home
on the
apartment building on the affordable
block the previously approved on the
left and the now proposed on the right
hand side
left side please
and again previously approved on the
left
and then that proposed on the right on
the particularly
okay so this is um
in the eastern part of the site what was
previously improved was um
some lone stone walls to the boundary
boundary of the plots and georgie the
blocks see then
that
is
now proposed to be um
railings instead of
those low
stone walls effectively what's been
found is through the detailed design
process that a lot of the part of the
site in the south eastern corner is
actually main ground
and that's causing problems from
the perspective of foundations for the
developer
and so this is their response to that
constraint really um
we've also
we've also committed those railings on
other parts of the site
[Music]
again what we've previously improved at
the top
of those bottoms
[Music]
and
so these are just some of the
perspectives that were included with the
original application the artists
impressions but i just thought might be
quite useful
to see
um in terms of the appearance the likely
change from
uh on the left we've also got railings
as i said these have been permitted up
in the north uh western part of the site
and
then on the right-hand side there the
low stone walls um some of which are now
being
proposed to be replaced by railings in
in the eastern part of the site
it looks like this
they're the same again you can see there
there's those stone walls
flip side please
again there are perspectives showing
both
[Music]
and then this is um
just a plan from the geophysical report
which basically that red area in the uh
in the south eastern part of the site is
the area of may ground
looks like he's home
and so to conclude there's obviously
quite a number of um amendments there
proposed facts affects a number of props
obviously that we've previously
um permitted
um but i think the majority of those
obviously are
are sort of minor detailing um in terms
of the
the various house types and a very
modest um change to parts of the layouts
as well
um so the application i mean doesn't
affect obviously the number of dwellings
that we've provided doesn't affect the
access
the majority of the layout is unaffected
as well
um and also no impact on sort of
biodiversity and value of the site or in
the surface water drainage valve
drainage or anything like that
and i think really going back to the
original um point about it was being
about the context of
the change
when you're looking at what's been
previously committed i think obviously
225 is a
development of significant scale and i
think in that context these these
changes minor as they are are
considered to be non-material really and
for that reason the officer's
recommendation is that the application
should be recruiting
thank you james
and the first and only speaker to this
application is mr angus cook
manager
and you've got three minutes to address
the committee thank you thank you chad
good morning i'm editing managing
director of demons
[Music]
firstly my thanks to james jackson as
case officer who is always professional
engaging and efficient throughout the
original reserve matters and the law
material for you today
demonstrating committed to delivering
housing that raises the quality of
desired bargains developments
this material amendment provides
multiple small architectural detailed
changes to the elevation of boundary
treatments across the site
these
changes are applied to all units
including the information dwellings to
lift the scheme and build a place in
communities held up by biddeford is an
exempt plan inspired by the local
connection
based on the advice of an architect
independent from the original design
we've added some additional features
that reinforce the four rule character
areas identified in the design and
access statement
submitted under the improved reserve
letters application
the advanced rural areas were proposing
the addition of brick pointed gables
stone to identify key pots rounded
reveals in rendered plots and timber
lintels to some windows forwarding
details to eaves along with crease and
tile seals the artificially found in
rural pharmacies in the area
all these draw from the area around this
consented skin
in the formal character zones we've
introduced contrasting buff and orange
brick banding in a high quality favorite
that speak at the heart of biddeford
alongside additional landing to form
black doors
um sorry asheville abandoning the former
black doors units of the central scheme
to deliver a sense of presence in the
near formal area
as with many things the development of
the scheme of this scale comes with
additional engineering challenges the
extent of nature which only become
apparent after the planning is secured
therefore the application also covers
the minor rotation of the terrace of
plots 24 to 27 to avoid historic mining
futures identified
appropriately secured properties against
any possible glass
alongside this area of lake ground an
area playground was identified at the
outset
and it's had some consequences in the
design when we're viewed in detail
working alongside our engineers has
identified that the proposed low stone
walls in this area would have an overly
deep foundation up to two meters deep to
support a low-level wall of only 900
millimeters
as responsible developers demonstrate
homes always have their own
sustainability and the amount of
additional concrete and the massive
unnecessary excavation not meet the high
standards we hold ourselves to
although the area of lake ground only
affects a few plots these in turn have a
larger effect on the street scene rather
than to deliver a disjointed speed scene
we've replaced all these walls in this
area with these stake regulars which are
bound for treatment where you can send
them in
being more flexible these do not require
as deep validations and we've further
enforced these with planting of
flowering evergreen hedges and sharing
submitted plans which do not develop the
statements in keeping with the real
character area
stage ratings and hedging are very much
in line with high quality design
all of these changes come at real cost
in fact in excess of 350 000 pounds
which we feel worth doing in the pursuit
of delivering advanced setting high
quality new community of homes
i therefore urge you to support your
office
thank
recommendations
thank you michigan
right well
normally
normally
uh
nah so that i'm i'm grateful for james
for
explaining in the reportedly
there's no legal definition of that
you've got to look at it in context and
decide
whether you support what proposal or not
in any given situation
i have no problem i have no problem at
all with
13 of these proposals not at all i think
the changes to the uh vernacular sort of
knowledge
is good i like the brick coins out all
that the link tools i like all those
changes
when i do have a problem is with
taking the stone walls out to this site
in its entirety
and that's what
i can't agree to because
if you look at the plan that james's
kindly blown up for us and the one that
was online anyway that i created
the red area
that was shown to be made of brand is
only down in this south eastern corner a
small area yet the storm storm walls
cover quite a large area
and i cannot accept that you need two
meter deep foundations for a 75 mil high
if this made of ground is such a
disaster area i already know them the
terraces
are all those houses being built there
if the ground is so bad this is the area
down here that was shown there to be
made up ground not always here and over
here
rotating those sport fights remind
dwelling mine
things in the area there
as we know there's a lot of minds will
reach the water
so it was on these i hoped
that when james went back to the to
denver homes and said look
these the
these stonewalls are integral to the
design and
and i think we all know when we all
remember
they start estates
and have done in the past and the start
of them brilliant you've got nice school
more raw time realistic the further you
go in the
and i think storm walls in these areas
when we first had this
uh application before it
looked brilliant and they do they look
really good i know there are posting
rails in some of the areas
and have no problem with them in some of
the areas but i also think in some of
the areas the stonewall is not good and
i can't accept you need two meter deep
foundations for 75 mil high family walls
when you're building all the houses
there in any of them business knows how
deep they're gonna have to go for those
foundations
so that was the sticking point so i said
to
we'd better take it to committee and let
the committee decide
but i think the storm walls were for me
an integral part of the design and
layout of the element of this day
and um
check and i'll just um quickly just
explain a bit about that just an
additional comment
thank you
so you mentioned really that the main
area of main ground is confined to quite
a small area in the south and
southeastern part of the site as shown
there
and then you can see on the on the
amendments map that i've given you that
actually number 14 does extend further
up along along that street and i didn't
clear that with the architect and really
he made the point that yet again well
you could have railings for just that
made grand park but they're not within
that same street scene then you'd be
switching back to a stone wall and i
think the architect felt that that would
be slightly an awkward really appearance
on within that stretch same street scene
and i tend to agree with it really yeah
james gentry
on the artist's impressions we had
stonewalls on one side of the road and
railings on there that were planted yeah
yeah i i understand you have them on
either side but i just wonder about that
appearance and that character if you
have them on the same side and then
you've got a stone wall and then a
sudden interruption and then straight
into radians but
um
this says
estate railings in there are the stone
walls yeah where should the low stone
walls are metals
yeah it's about to be number 15 but
still in there
in the western part of the site there
would still be no stone walls
effectively councilman
application um
i don't agree with you all we all have
different views on the stone wall now
the radius to me is more appropriate and
with the implementation of planting more
green
greenery
even more fantastic for there to be
honest you know we're putting stone over
greenery you know
to me
biodiversity aren't for any any more
plants that we get in the area for the
developers
i think the designing foot forward is a
fantastic design there's not many
developers you see in the area to tweak
it around to spend more additional money
to upgrade these properties to me it's
more aesthetically pleasing to the eye
where you see we're reducing the gables
to the hip roofs
it's more than keeping with the area
that's my best opinion i think the
design that they've done is absolutely
fantastic to be honest i don't own any
homes from there i've never done any
work for them so i have donkey in your
interest
before i have that there if i get border
parts i'm addressing the gear
um
i think it's a really good design but um
with the bridge readings i'd like that
gives more of an open field in my mind
for your state it's more open and
unfortunate we all know we're in video
for that moment
the little retrovisions running around
with the graffiti and the social
behavior we have so there's less
opportunity for them to do anything
on the walls and if you're going to be
pessimistic but i'm an optimist and i
like the design they've done i'm pretty
sure
this would be good for the area so
the decision before you today of whether
the changes are material it's not
necessarily whether
a design is appropriate we certainly
aren't being asked to assess it against
our policies
but it's all about looking at that
context and
there are railings and stones walls or
stonewalls already within the
development it's where you support these
changes
being a non-material amendment
thank you that clarification
helen
yes
i i think this is
this is damn good james that what this
what it's been changed into is far far
superior to what there was there before
and and as as dermot is saying yeah the
railings are fine they are fine uh
and
i look now but between
the one that was set up in the first
place and they've come back and and it's
costing them money i know it's costing
them money to do brickwork instead of
render
rounding rounding um
corners off and i just i've done it i've
been there and actually done it and know
the costs what it is and so he got your
blood and wanted to do this it looked
fantastic
and
apart from that
everything else to me all all these
amendments are fine
and
okay well as i said i agree with all the
majority of all those changes you've
mentioned it's just these
abandonment of the stonewalls that i
wouldn't support
anybody else want to make any comments
and we're looking at whether this is a
number or not
a material consideration
right okay so
who's moved have you moved so we accept
the grant this thing yesterday
and council watching you said
[Music]
[Music]
four councillor golf four
council watson
yeah
four
cancer wise man
unanimous chair
thank you chandra great
move on with the agenda then i make
appeals decisions there are no field
decisions to report
nine on the agenda is costs on appeals
so there are no costs
item 10 on the agenda
on pages 76
77
40 76
um
[Music]
agnd
decisions there you've got those listed
list of planning decisions
concept free abbreviations and
applications actually from the 28th of
april to the 26th of may
77 78 79
1881
18 yeah the very first application the
dna variation i'm coming
106 one is i assume that the world
members were involved in this discussion
do i know council prince is always
backed on about section 106 involving
uh
screen 84 85
86
and 87 you've got those
refused uh
why i declared that
that's the end of the meeting there's no
exclusion of public options so
i declare them